okay today I'm going to talk to you
about changes in momentum I'm going to
show you this equation here how to use
it how it applies to real life
situations and the importance of crumple
zones on cars so um first of all it's
important to note for the for your GT se
you do not need to memorize this
equation you'll be given it but you will
need to know how to use it so let's
imagine there's two situations first of
all let's imagine there's a van here
with no crumple zone explain what does
crumple zone is in just a minute so
let's imagine I've got this van here
apologies my aweful torian's unless I've
got this phone here and it hasn't got a
crumple zone now crumple zone is a part
of a vehicle it is specially designed in
order to crumple upon impact in order to
make the crash lust for a slightly
longer duration and we'll see why that's
important in a minute so let's imagine
this van has gone out of control and
it's going to smash into that wall there
so let's say this van is 2,000 kilograms
and it's speeding into that wall at
speed of 10 meters per second when it
hits into the wall that says a really
firm wall it would just come to a halt
so what we need to be able to do is we
need to be able to do this calculation
here so first of all remember the
momentum is mass multiplied by velocity
so they're either the greater the mass
or the fast and objects going the
greater its momentum so so this one here
the force at the beginning is the mass
so 2,000 multiplied by its final
velocity now its final velocity as it's
hitting into the wall and coming to a
stop it's going to be zero meters per
second so it's going to be 2,000 times
zero takeaway 2000 because the mass
hasn't changed even though it's coming
into the wall the mass times the initial
velocity which is 10 meters per second
now the time it's taken let's say this
whole collision it took one second so
it's at one second for it to come so
so the whole thing would be divided by
one okay let's just simplify that so two
thousand times zero is zero and then two
thousand times ten is twenty thousand
divided by one so the force is minus
twenty thousand divided by one the
answer to that is just minus twenty
thousand Newtons
because I've just divided by one so it's
just a minus twenty thousand now notice
it's a minus number this is because the
force is in the opposite direction to
the driver now that's a huge amount of
force to be put onto a person which is
the reason why I lot lot the time people
get really badly injured or killed in
car accidents now this car didn't have a
compazine this van did not have a
crumple zone let's see how it would be
different if this one had a crumple zone
so what we'll imagine now is we'll have
the exact same van so as a result it's
meant to be the same even though I'll
probably accidentally draw it a bit
differently it's meant to be the same so
again we've got two thousand kilograms
just as before again we're smashing into
the wall at the same speed of 10 meters
per second but now this one has a
crumple zone fitted now what that means
is it's designed to kind of crumple upon
impact making the time of this collision
last for longer so let's say instead of
one second this collision lasted for two
seconds instead let's just see the mass
behind that then so the force is going
to be so that's the mass which is two
thousand times the final velocity again
it's coming to a halt so its final
velocity will be zero
takeaway let me see take away the mass
which hasn't changed times the initial
velocity so all of that so far is the
same as the first instance because we've
got the same van now the difference is
this time we're dividing by two instead
of two by one because it took longer
what we then need to do is this two
thousand times zero is zero take away
twenty thousand just this before this
time two
by two so it's gonna be minus 20000
/ - now - 20,000 divided by 2 equals
minus 10,000 Newton's so can we see this
one has got half of the force acting on
the person remember this got the - no
because the forces acting the opposite
direction to the motion it's got half
the force acting on the person so by
having that crumple zone which increases
the amount of time the collision occurs
for we are given this person a much
better chance of being able to survive
this is why crumple zones and seat belts
are used because they prolong the amount
of time the collision happens for
therefore the change in momentum is or
sorry the force exerted upon the person
is much less that is how to use this
equation and that is changes in momentum
thank you